in Eastern Africa Somalia is facing
poverty and hunger on an unprecedented
scale UNICEF says more than half a
million children are at risk of dying by
the middle of this year unless urgent
action is taken a child is admitted to a
hospital suffering malnutrition every
minute of every day drought and a
20-year Insurgency by militants have
already made a desperate situation even
worse Deborah Potter traveled to badoa
in Somalia and met the mothers who risk
everything for their Starving Children
her report may be hard to watch
this used to be empty land now a refuge
for those fleeing climate change and
conflict over two years of drought has
left Southern Somalia desolate and
villages with a stock Choice stay and
face starvation or leave and risk the
Fighting waged by one of al-qaeda's
Deadliest Affiliates al-shabab every day
the depleted the desperate and the
near-dying arrive in baidoa Weak with
hunger
ability Ali and her daughters just got
here after traveling over 70 miles
I've come to find food and medicine she
tells us back home there is nothing to
eat it's too dangerous for Aid
organizations to enter her Village and
any food that does reach there is
weaponized
al-shabab controls supplies Ali told us
if they haven't authorized it they burn
the food the mood across the camp
suddenly shifts an al-shabab fighter has
been spotted amongst the tents police
have been alerted
it's not easy working in Somalia we've
just been told a suspected militant has
been arrested and that means we have to
leave
at a different refugee camp we find
Habiba Muhammad who fled
al-shabub-controlled territory after her
crops failed to grow for a fifth
consecutive season with no rain
it's the worst drought I've ever
experienced in my life she said
Muhammad was eight months pregnant when
she walked with her three-year-old son
for six days to find food when we met
her she'd given birth to baby Assad just
three days earlier
I was all alone she told us nobody was
around to help in a makeshift shelter
with no water and no food she was forced
to cut her own umbilical cord
baby Assad was born hungry but Muhammad
has made the perilous journey to save
him from famine for when children are
starving a mother's courage knows no
bounds for CBS mornings Deborah Pasha
baidoa Somalia
you can learn more about unicef's work
in Somalia at their website at
unicef.org appeals slash Somalia